[Music]
no one is born the same and that's the
beauty of nature but some creatures are
more unique than what we are used to
seeing their difference can be what
makes them really cute or even famous
scientists tried to study these
beautiful little monsters and couldn't
find an answer to all their questions
just wait until you see a dog who lived
a beautiful life with only two legs if
you love animals as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you 10 monsters science cannot
explain the two-faced cats who said that
monsters couldn't be cute if you want a
lot of cats you could get two for the
price of one Frank and Louie also named
Frank and Louie were born with two faces
instead of one they're what we call a
Janus cat inspired by the Roman god who
is often portrayed with two faces
scientists don't clearly understand what
could cause that they know that a
variety of genetic mechanisms and too
many proteins could be responsible for
this unique characteristic but they
can't find a specific cause sharing the
same brain and having only one esophagus
is probably what gave these cats a
chance to survive two-faced animals are
extremely rare and this is why Frank and
Louie keep making the news but what is
even more incredible is that they lived
until the age of 15 until they passed
away in 2014 this is how they held the
Guinness Book of World Records title for
the longest live Janus cat two-faced
animals don't usually live for a long
time due to health problems moreover
they are often abandoned or even eaten
by their mother after birth because of
their difference but Frank and Louie had
the chance to live a beautiful life at
their compassionate owner they lived as
long as any other cat would and we bet
that they were smiling twice as much as
other animals the octa go to what
happens when a goat has a baby with an
octopus nothing this is impossible but
this is probably what many people
thought when they saw this unique
creature this goat was born with eight
legs in Croatia
it was also both male and female when a
farmer saw this he couldn't believe his
eyes he counted the legs many times and
even called his neighbor to make sure
that he wasn't dreaming the goat was
trying to stand up on its eight legs but
wasn't strong enough yet unfortunately
unique little monsters like this don't
have a lot of chances to survive but if
they make it to a week they are likely
to live for up to three years
veterinarians think that this double
goat was caused by an underdeveloped
twin sibling they would
grown up in the same body causing the
animal to have eight legs and two
biological genders it's like two goats
mixed together but it is still difficult
to clearly understand what happened in
the womb and the farmer doesn't see it
as a monster he said that the birth of
the creature was a miracle of nature and
we have to agree with him if it were
still alive after one week he would like
to keep it as a pet we don't know what
happened to this beautiful creature but
we want to give it a name we would call
it Octavio or Octavia we'll let it
choose the gender that it prefers if you
want to watch just one more video the
premium is the platform where you should
go get early access to videos from the
things the taco the trendy the richest
and many other great channels in one
place with ad free browsing click this
link to sign up for free to the premium
and get ready to binge watch videos from
your favorite channels the headless
chicken why did the chicken cross the
road to get to the other side but what
if this joke was darker than what we
imagined what if the chicken actually
wanted to get hit by a car to go to
heaven you'll never look at this joke
the same way again
but fortunately one chicken survived
when a farmer tried to cut its head
usually when you cut the head of a
chicken it can appear to live for up to
15 minutes as the legs keep moving but
wait until you see what happened to this
chicken called Mike on September 10th
1945 Lloyd Olsen and his wife were
cutting the heads of chickens on their
farm but one of them did something that
they didn't expect the chicken was still
alive and just casually walking around
even though there was no head on its
shoulders they put it in a box thinking
that its life would end there but when
they woke up the next morning Mike was
still alive when people learned about
this the local newspaper decided to
report this weird event and someone
invited the couple to travel all around
the country with this little miracle
they kept Michael ID by feeding him with
liquid food directly into his esophagus
and clearing mucus from his throat this
is how the chicken lived for 18 months
without a head beating the odds and
proving that everything is possible the
Hindu god some people are terrified when
they see something different
ignorance leads to fear and fear leads
to hate this is why any creature that
stands out from others could be rejected
but this is not what this Indian
community thought when they saw this
little monster they took what nature
offered them and decided to honor it
this creature born from a cow had
human-like features
had nose ears and eyes similar to ours
this is what made many people believe
that it was an avatar of God
unfortunately this animal passed away an
hour after it was brought to this world
but Indians made sure that its short
life would be remembered for a long time
they placed it in a glass box so
everyone could see it it wasn't long
before everyone in the city and even
people from the neighboring villages
wanted to see this unique baby they came
there to seek its blessing and offer it
flowers thousands of people came to
visit this little God
the creature was cremated three days
after and the little temple was built
for it so we know what religious people
think of this animal but what about
scientists they said that a gene simply
didn't develop properly and caused the
abnormality but we're still missing a
lot of details to clearly understand why
this calf was born like that what if God
really made no mistake and wanted people
to be reunited around this animal to
celebrate the beauty of nature the
three-headed frog we have already seen a
cat with two faces and a twin who
developed in the body of a goat but just
when you thought that it couldn't get
weirder Nature surprised us one more
time this frog doesn't only have one
face or even two it has three heads and
six legs the creature was found in the
garden of a nursery the staff caught it
and placed it in a tank
everyone was fascinated by this little
creature a woman who works at the
nursery said that she wanted to call the
frogs good bad and ugly but the kids
decided to name it froggy instead the
animal quickly became famous and many
people went to the nursery to take a
look at it
scientists had never heard of an animal
like this before they said that mutant
frogs had been reported for the past 200
years but a frog with three heads is
really rare they think that it might
have been caused by a parasite or a
genetic defect pollution could also be
responsible for that as it had an impact
on the frogs hormones unfortunately
before they could find an answer to all
of their questions
the little celebrity had disappeared
hopping out of its tank we don't know if
they had the chance to capture it or if
froggy simply hopped away from all this
attention
the four-legged duck are you ready for
another dose of cuteness since its birth
stumpy has been one of the most famous
little ducks born in February 2007 he
surprised his owners who couldn't
believe what they were seeing when they
wanted to look at it to see if it were a
male or a female they saw something else
on its bottom with four legs
this creature fascinated everyone who
thought that this difference made him
adorable stumpy wasn't supposed to live
for a long time because of his mutation
and
no chance to survive in nature but he
made the news again months later when
people saw that he had survived with the
good care of its owner the animal
learned to walk on only two of its legs
he is not allowed to walk around on the
farm because his owner is afraid that
its legs might get caught somewhere this
is why a big pen was made to keep it
safe and it seems to be happier than
ever
stumpy loves the attention it's getting
the duck appeared on television and
photo shoots to celebrate the fact that
it is still alive it also helped
scientists by offering a blood sample so
they could study genetic mutations and
this story has a happy ending stumpy
found love it has been paired up with a
female duck named Alice we can't wait to
see what the little baby ducks look like
the five legged cow there's nothing
wrong with being different and this
confident cow knows it if we were born
with a third leg most of us would
probably try to hide it but this cow
with a fifth leg knew that there was
nothing to be ashamed of and its owner
gave it the chance to celebrate its
difference the cow is a holy animal in
India and they call it their mother this
is why its owner thinks that the cow
holds the essence of Hindu religion as
the manifestation of the Hindu deity he
thinks that God is sending a message in
his fifth leg to tell them to respect
the animal and touching its fifth leg
would bring us good luck people from
far-off districts used to go to his home
to see the cow seek blessing and make
donations this is why the owner had to
find another way to show the cow to
everyone he said that he wanted all of
the humanity to benefit from the
blessings of the mother cow and its
fifth leg at four years old the cow was
taken on a tour in India and it got the
attention of many people
the owner already visits six states and
15 major cities and the animal is always
really popular hundreds of people wanted
to see it at each location and there is
something that we should learn from this
beautiful cow our difference is our
greatest strength the eunuch ow who said
that unicorns don't exist just because
you haven't seen one doesn't mean that
it's impossible for them to live on this
planet or maybe we just don't know what
we should be looking for
what if unicorns look like cows instead
of horses if you don't believe us
just look at what we are going to call
the eunuch cow the animal was born in
Uzbekistan with two normal horns on the
side of its head and another one on its
forehead
at first the farmer was afraid that the
cow would be rejected by the others
because of its difference but instead
the little cow used its third horn to
bully other calves and poke them out of
the way that's not what you should do
little cow fortunately this third horn
does
cause any trouble to the cow it just has
to work on its behavior and it is going
to live a happy life just like the other
animals but why was it born like that is
it a sign that magical creatures really
do exist many people thought that the
third horn was a sign of pollution and
its effect on the natural world but
other people loved it this animal was
born this way and wanted other cows to
be bred like it wouldn't it be great to
create a new breed of eunuch house the
two-legged dog have you ever heard that
life would never put more on you than
you can handle
it means that whatever challenge you
have to face in life there will always
be a way to get through it even if it is
really hard and to inspire you will tell
you the story of faith the two-legged
dog when her owner Katie saw the three
week old pup with two legs and a
deformation she didn't think that she
would survive the night a vet even
suggested euthanasia but Katie decided
to take her back home instead she
described faith as tiny and adorable she
knew that this little dog needed help
they amputated the deformed leg and
nursed the little puppy to make sure
that it felt better then the next
challenge was to find a way to let the
dog move around without groveling on the
floor otherwise it couldn't survive they
use peanut butter to motivate her to sit
and they were surprised to see that she
accomplished that goal very quickly and
then everyone was shocked when they saw
that the dog also learned to walk on her
two legs during her life faith visited a
lot of veterans and hospitals and many
of them broke up in tears the dog was
proof that if an animal can go through
this they can do it too
faith passed away in 2014 after changing
the lives of many people the half-human
half-beast some little monsters are
terrifyingly cute others are treated
like gods and some are less lucky than
others but that doesn't mean that we
should treat them differently as every
creature deserves love when this
creature was born from a sheep people
thought that it was sent from hell it
looked like a fat deformed naked child
more than 4,000 people in South Africa
were convinced that the animal was the
result of witchcraft and bestiality
they panicked so much that they asked
experts to take care of the situation
and it quickly caught the attention of
veterinarians they immediately confirmed
that it was not a hoax but not the devil
either it might look like a human but it
has nothing to do with it it is simply
impossible for a man to have a baby with
a sheep because the animal has 28 pairs
of chromosomes and we only have 23 pairs
it was simply a severely deformed lamb
it was probably infected by a fever at
an early stage of the pregnancy and for
the creature was not alive when it was
born but we hope that it is in a better
world now if you found a unique little
monster like any of those on this list
would you like to adopt them don't be
shy to tell us what you think in the
comment section down below and that's it
for 10 monsters science cannot explain
if you want to see more stories like
this make sure you watch 10 people who
accidentally adopted monsters thanks for
watching
[Music]